I can asked about the question about
peak oil a lot and the question is well
we have a limited amount of oil well yes
we do have a limited amount of oil we
have a limited amount of television
cameras and Rolex watches and light
bulbs and you name it there's a there's
a finite number of everything my
response to the the Peak Oil arguments
are okay so what yes we're going to hit
a peak oil production at some point in
the future when that is no one can
predict but the point is that as the
price of oil rises entrepreneurs
innovators are going to come up with new
ways to find oil and get it out of the
ground and further that the issue as
that price rises demand has to stay in
balance with supply you can't have more
demand in the supply the price
eventually will will crush demand at a
certain point and they will they will
stay in balance the good news for the US
which i think is people may not say it's
good news but we can afford higher oil
prices more easily than can say Pakistan
or India we are we're wealthier country
we have more disposable income and so we
are going to see as oil or natural gas
or any commodity becomes more expensive
Rolex watches they are rationed by price
and in fact we have rationing by price
today on virtually every commodity not
everyone can eat at 21 club not everyone
wears a Rolex everything is rationed by
price as energy prices rise we will see
more pronounced rationing by price of
energy commodities and I think that
that's inevitable the good news is that
as the price rises we'll see more
innovation and more alternatives come
into the market whatever that may be
whether it's batteries in cars or you
know some other liquid fuel not ethanol
that may come into the market